so do you think
something like proof of stake that's
more about
reputation than um
than an actual exertion like
energy can work no i think proof of
stake is inherently centralizing
um it's like the old matthew principle
from those who have to those who have
more will be given from those who have
not
everything will be taken that's what
proof of stake is
you need proof of work to embody skin in
the game in the marketplace
such that contributions are
commensurate with consideration received
that's how systems work
what's the idea why proof of work might
incentivize decentralization
like do you worry that uh
as bitcoin becomes more powerful it may
become again
more centralized well
the decentralization of bitcoin
is largely driven by the nodes actually
which
aren't actually mining they're just
choosing which rule set to implement
um and then the the mining network is
actually enforcing that rule set
so i think the mining network
is inherently decentralized in that
really anyone with access to cheap
energy
can become a miner you can freely enter
or exit the market
or the network at any time
but maintaining the block size at a
manageable level is what's key to
maintaining node decentralization
it's an interesting question who do you
think has more power the minors and the
nodes
because the nodes carry the uh
the idea of the protocol like the the
specifics
so in some sense they have more power
like bitcoin is an idea
they're kind of mutually indispensable
though because you can't have
there's no security without the miners
so without the miners bitcoin is just an
idea
and we've the idea of bitcoin has maybe
existed even before bitcoin right just
sound money we just say sound money is
an idea
but there was no way to root that into
thermodynamic reality without
satoshi figuring out not just proof of
work it's the entire
composite of the difficulty adjustment
proof of work
uh one-way hashing etc so
i don't know that's hard to say hard to
disentangle the two
you